okay today i have with me yet another of
these
language entrepreneurs that are changing
the way languages are learned
by creating content systems
advice uh approaches to learning that
are
helping people in a way that the old
language schools i think
didn't today we have pablo pablo
roman humanes who has a website or a
a channel on youtube called dreaming
spanish pablo perhaps you could
introduce yourself
hi steve uh thanks for the introduction
so
yes um i me and other
teachers were making content we're
making comprehensible input
videos based on the ideas of stephen
krashen
as as i know you know him and you've
done some videos with him
so there they really follow uh the
research
on language language acquisition over
the last few
decades and so we try to make
content that's as useful and as as
interesting as possible
you know something that struck me today
was
so right now there's a big debate as to
whether people should go back to school
you know in class learning i go back to
university in class learning in
universities
the universities want to hold on to
their income so they're
trying to insist that the students come
to class
and in all of that i was thinking to
myself you know
the big difference today is at least
when it comes to languages but
probably it applies to other things as
well why do we assume
that learning has to be synchronous in
other words
you have a teacher and while a teacher
is teaching
the learners are learning it doesn't
work that way
you can create a variety of content that
is
you know from a learning from a didactic
point of view very rich
and the learner can access it whenever
he or she wants
it can be asynchronous it doesn't have
to be
you know while a lecturer is lecturing
yeah i think we're used to the
traditional paradigm in which
there's a teacher and providing us with
information
but of course in the information age
that
doesn't hold as well right and i get it
that for language learning
for many people learning a language is
about connection and about the people
you meet with that language
and i still think if you can meet a
person
if you can meet in person and make
friends with the language that's
a really um efficient way of spending
your time
but most of the time you cannot if
you're driving around you're walking
going
for groceries or doing something right
there's of course a lot of benefit you
can get there or
you're stuck at home because there's
confinement because of
kovit then there's a lot of time on your
hands that you can make the most of if
you have as you say asynchronous content
right yes the benefit of being able to
choose whatever
interests you well well that's right but
if you take a classroom
so the classroom teacher interacts with
10
20 30 or in the case of a university
lecturer
200 people so one person with
20 or 200 people it seems to me it makes
more sense if each one of those people
were able to learn on their own and then
there would be
less interaction with the teacher but it
would be more personal
so instead of having five classes a week
you have one class a week and the rest
of time you're using
content that you produce for spanish
you're searching
conjugations uh you know wherever you
find them because there's no limit to
the amount of resources to to to check
up
on you know what what form of the verb
is this
uh and then you interact in a much more
personal way
with a teacher to me that's superior to
a teacher
trying to teach the same thing to 20
people in the classroom
yeah definitely because in case of a
classroom with so many people there's
not even that
element of like personalization or
personal connection because
you're nice too many people so that
benefit is also also disappears so yeah
as you say makes more sense
now i saw on your channel you talk about
you know
sort of not not eliminating grammar but
de-emphasizing grammar
uh you're i would say i kind of
eliminate grammar okay you even
eliminated all right you're more radical
than i am
uh but um and then you say dreaming in
spanish and and so it's this
idea that the language is somehow gonna
enter
into you and the brain gets used to it
one of the problems that people
people often raise is so in the
beginning you know nothing so there's no
comprehensive
comprehensible input at level zero
because you know nothing
so that there is no yeah i would say
there's no input
that you cannot base yourself only on
the words that you're
hearing to understand what's happening
right but it can be comprehensible if
there's enough
context enough additional information
true enough true enough
yeah but at least insofar as the kind of
learning that i do where i'm
with my ipod and i'm walking running
doing the dishes initially there's no
comprehension i don't understand what
they're saying
i've got to claw my way through a lot of
repetition
to where i make some sense of this and
and there's a lot of beginner content
out there in every language
there's a super abundance of beginner
content
everybody who writes a textbook starts
with the beginner stuff
however very soon because
as i've often mentioned word frequency
drops off
very quickly so you have this sense that
you've seen these high frequency verbs
or words so often and stuff and now you
start to venture and all sudden you
discover that there's an awful lot of
words
to learn and there seems to be a lack
of easily sort of comprehensible
approachable
intermediate content because if you go
straight to the
authentic stuff it's just a little bit
difficult so how do you deal with that
that need for something that's not silly
not
childish not beginner yet not at
full-blown authentic level
uh i don't know that that we've
completely cracked it
and i think over time we'll probably get
better at this
but right now what we do is uh we try to
focus on topics
that are interesting for adults
or for for everybody uh we
one thing that we realize that can be
even if there's not that
extra information of visual props or
drawing
there's two things that can still make
you more comprehensible
than uh input for natives or media for
natives
one is just uh
articulating properly and not
not speaking too fast and the other way
the other thing that also helps is not
changing topics
randomly because that's something that
if you watch a youtuber if you watch a
tv show
they start a conversation and if you
don't know what's going on who these
those people are
you don't have a lot of context to begin
to even begin to understand what they're
saying
and in our case maybe we'll make a video
um
five or ten minute video you've seen the
title so you know what it's gonna be
about
and it within all the video it stays
within the same topic
right certainly that's true and that's
true even on the
on the level of choosing an author like
when i started
reading books in russian i would just
read tolstoy and as long as i was
reading tolstoy
it seemed the same vocabulary would come
up whereas if i went to dostoyevsky all
of a sudden i was lost
uh and if you're talking about economics
or
so you stay on a subject you do get the
same vocabulary tending to
definitely so that's a way of choosing
content that's
at your level is if what you're reading
from that author
is still easy enough for you to enjoy
but hard enough that you still
encounter new words then you can just
stay within that topic or within that
offer
is if as you said before uh you're
at the point in which there's no low
frequency vocabulary anymore
you feel you're not learning right just
by changing authors you're gonna see
that there's many
new words that you encounter often right
but
you don't yet know right
now another subject so you de-emphasize
grammar you don't teach grammar
and we know we both agree that speaking
another language is a matter of
developing new habits
so if you're an english speaker then you
are in the habit of always using the
personal pronoun for example that's just
natural you're in the habit of making no
distinction between certain and star
it's just be uh you're in the ha you are
not in the habit of using the
subjunctive
so how do you create these habits
you can explain to a person like i often
use the example in english you can
explain to a person that the third
person singular the present
tense takes s and yet that's a very
common mistake that every you know
non-native speaker makes that they don't
you know he go inside if he goes
so understanding the principle and
actually developing these habits those
are two different things
how do you get your spanish learners to
develop spanish habits so the way our
method works is by trying to
build a separate picture of the language
in your brain
trying to keep connections between the
two languages as little as possible
in such a way that english will not
affect your output once you start
outputting once you start speaking
spanish so we try to reduce the amount
of interference that your native
language will have with the language
that you learn
by right doing input without
translation trying to not translate no
not even
connect those things between the two
languages because i would say even sarah
and star
they're not to be they're not the same
so we're trying to the idea with our
method would be that you wouldn't even
make the connection between
to be and sarah and start
yeah okay
okay that's interesting interesting yeah
because i mean i know
i often mention this speakers of english
say
germans who speak you know fluent
english and they'll still say i have
been living in canada
since many years which is a german
structure it's not
english structure and they just cannot
shake certain habits that come from
their native language
and we all experience this i mean i'm i
probably when i speak spanish
i use the personal pronoun more than a
native speaker would use it
because these are habits that come over
from your native language
so i guess you're never going to get
perfection but you want to try to
get people to migrate more into a
spanish
mode and so you do this by
trying to break the connection with
their name so yeah yeah and it's based
on the
on research about comprehensible input
and
my own experience trying to also stick
to this method to learn languages and
comparing it to other languages that
i've learned through more traditional
methods
and it's all based on the experience of
uh one linguist that developed this
method in a school
in in bangkok where they teach thai so
i i experienced that i learned thai
there myself
to learn the method and now i'm trying
to apply to to spanish
okay now we're going to leave a link to
your channel
in the description box and just to tell
uh my viewers here which languages do
you speak besides very good english
spanish i presume and thai what whatever
so yeah my native languages are
spanish and catalan i'm catalan
and then i speak english french japanese
and
thai i see okay
um i always ask this question catalan
between say
hirona and valencia is there sure
there's uh i would say there's
catalan changes uh more than spanish
within like less distance
so you can drive for but mutually
mutually comprehensive yeah totally
mutually comprehensible yes
but maybe between girona and valencia it
can change just matches between
uh spanish between madrid and mexico or
something
oh yeah very interesting okay well we
got
catalan at the link so maybe one day
i'll learn it lovely part of the world
my wife and i for our 50th anniversary
we were in uh
in tarragona which was lovely and
in hirona and uh yeah uh so on
the video in my channel i hope you tell
us about your experience
in the latin world oh for sure okay yeah
yeah we're now going to have a spanish
discussion for
for his channel so people who are
interested can also go and visit us
there
great all right then thank you talking
to you enjoyed it
okay bye